[Musica]
perché ci occupiamo di uno in tre gruppi
perché riteniamo che siano l'iniziativa
fantastica ed essendo io di como perché
è a 40 chilometri dalla nostra città ma
procediamo con ordine
c'è una volta expo 2015 e suonare anche
la celebrata la micra l'ospitata un
milione di metri cubi sta crescendo mind
milano innovation il district un
formidabile ecosistema per l'innovazione
che rappresenta un investimento in
ricerca e formazione fra i più
importanti d'europa e questo come
dicevamo a 40 km va come riteniamo che
un territorio in prossimità di una
iniziativa così significativa debba
tenere alta la propria attenzione
attenzione positiva se vuole valorizzare
le opportunità che di questa iniziativa
decideranno chi aveva chiara demand e in
parte già operativo e human techno il
nuovo straordinaria centro di ricerca
italiano per le scienze della vita
presidente dalla costituzione nel 2018 e
della fondazione newman te non puoi
professor marco simoni marco simonit al
2014 al 2018
e stato consigliere del presidente della
kore del consiglio dei ministri del
governo italiano per le relazioni
economiche internazionali e per la
politica fiat prima ancora per nove anni
ha svolto attività di insegnamento e di
ricerca presso la prestigiosa london
school of economics il professor si
vorrebbe qui con noi
innanzitutto grazie professor simoni di
aver accettato ad un dito e vuole
iniziare con una mia curiosità come lato
newman tecnopolo e melata sto di chi
nella testa di roberto cingolani che era
uno dei tre direttori dell'istituto
italiano di tecnologia e di un altro
gruppo di scienziati e nel 2015 quando
stavamo ragionando io all'epoca lavorava
col presidente del consiglio matteo
renzi di come fare a rivitalizzare
l'area in cui si stava tenendo l'expo
avevamo iniziato a lavorare sul futuro
sul post expo nella prima gio carri ma
che ci fosse l'expo dalla fine del 2014
ma mancava un idea centrale ovvero un
nuovo quartiere come fa a nascere e
svilupparsi se non c'è niente se
soltanto un terreno per quanto ben
infrastrutturato ben collegato con
l'alta velocità che ci arrivava dentro
la metropolitana eccetera ma il rischio
che correva era di fare la fine di tutti
gli altri expo di cui abbiamo memoria
ovvero una landa abbandonata desolata e
allora tra le tante idee che che furono
portate avanti arrivo questa che passò
poi un vaglio molto complesso di
discussioni con decine e decine di
centri studi in italia centri di ricerca
e anche una come si dice peer review c'è
un'analisi ceca fatta da grandi esperti
internazionali che poi portò il progetto
io manterrò commissione specifica un
nuovo polo
la missione specifica e lavorare per la
medicina predittiva e la medicina
personalizzata ovvero fare avanzamenti
nella conoscenza della biologia umana e
anche del contesto in cui la biologia
umana opera quindi anche da tipo sociale
di tipo economico per arrivare a fare in
modo che non tra cento anni ma tra in un
futuro a noi a noi prossimo sia
possibile grazie agli avanzamenti negli
studi genetici agli avanzamenti negli
studi di big data arrivare a trovare la
cura specifica per la malattia di ognuno
e addirittura riuscire a sapere in
anticipo di cosa uno è più probabile che
si ammali e quindi da prevenire quindi
curarsi prevenendo prima che sorga la
malattia
cosa c'è di straordinario di particolare
il tecnopolo rispetto agli altri centri
di ricerca italiani e stranieri c'è
qualche cosa per lo caro tradizione un
modo particolare diciamo che rispetto al
panorama italiano con la caratteristica
fondamentale di human technokolla è
quella di avere delle di ospitare delle
grandi tecnologie che ancora in italia
non esiste ma non stiamo proprio in
questo
montando le prime perché sono finiti da
pochi lavori dei nostri laboratori
queste grandi tecnologie saranno a
disposizione di tutto l'ecosistema della
ricerca italiano quindi è più che un
solo un centro di ricerca e un albo
alcune caratteristiche in comune con
paul con i grandi centri di ricerca
internazionali come the king istituti
londra armati chiariti parigi ovvero un
luogo molto internazionale è
un'istituzione italiana e internazionale
in quella lingua di lavoro e l'inglese
che noi oggi siamo appena all'inizio del
nostro processo di crescita abbiamo
circa 100 dipendenti che però diciamo un
buon risultato con tanto che abbiamo
iniziato due anni fa con un solo
dipendente e ad oggi abbiamo circa
dodici nazionalità presenti e stanno
crescendo perché gli scienziati vengono
da tutto il mondo e sono naturalmente di
tutte le nazionalità
quindi un luogo internazionale che punta
ad essere un luogo di eccellenza
scientifica quindi prendendo i migliori
scienziati che può riuscire ad assumere
a questa è una caratteristica in comune
ad altri centri di ricerca
internazionali di grande scala
la sua specificità e che le nostre
tecnologie sono tecnologie aperte quindi
uno scienziato che lavora non è un'altra
università regolarmente può venire da
noi con dei banditi visiting professor
ship
oppure con delle specifiche colpe
progetti per usare in maniera autonoma
indipendente le nostre strumentazioni
questo serve a fare in modo che tutta la
ricerca italiana potrà giovarsi il
nostro centro perché come avere delle
nuove tecnologie a disposizione di tutti
vede per loro natura queste tecnologie
sono grandi complicati da mantenere
molto sofisticate non si può ogni paese
già un luogo in cui ci possono esserci
invece possono essere tanti di
laboratorio di genomica ad alto
throughput come si suol dire ovvero cup
grande capacità di sequenziare migliaia
e migliaia di genomi però importante che
ci sia almeno uno che poi possiamo usare
tutti economista di formazione di
professione come avete vada valutato
possibile impatto di un centro di
ricerca di questa levatura complessivo
ovviamente
specificamente per il territorio in cui
in cui si trova guardi l'impatto di
questa edizione si può difficilmente
sovrastimare nel senso che è un impatto
che abbraccia un enorme varietà di
effetti il primo naturalmente quello
scientifico
noi la rivista science è vista molto
famosa che tutti conoscono
in questo momento l'ultimo numero uscito
ospite in copertina un articolo della
vicedirettrice del nostro dipartimento
di biologia strutturale avere una lista
di importante con un articolo così
importante affiliato all'università con
un centro di ricerca italiano questo è
un beneficio per tutto il paese di di
conoscenza di reputazione in un vertice
importante per chiunque lavori di una
ricerca italiana perché mostra che la
ricerca le raccoglie le grandi scopi
naturalmente questa ricerca non è stata
svolta in quante propoli cerca di lavoro
per noi e quindi accade così normalmente
che anche la sua affiliazione nuova
compagna nel suo articolo
naturalmente pubblicato quindi si vada
da questo effetto che l'affetto di
reputazione importante per tutti
all'effetto naturalmente per la scienza
per il fatto che tanti scienziati
potranno usare queste nuove tecnologie
quindi facendo ricerche più importanti e
più significative di quelle che
avrebbero potuto fare senza questa
tecnologia si va l'effetto economico
perché l'area che ospita human tecnopolo
è un'area grande come un quartiere molto
grande di una città in cui amo 23
palazzi di quell'area
uno deve essere ancora costruito ma
attorno a noi sta già struggendo una
cittadella della scelta dell'innovazione
perché aziende arrivato un pezzo
dell'università statale grande un grande
ospedale che siamo i galeazzi si stanno
trasferendo attorno a noi perché trovano
naturale l'interazione con un grande
centro di ricerca di queste dimensioni
questo porta nuovi investimenti
nell'area importanti nuovi investimenti
in italia perché una serie importante di
multinazionali decidono di mettere i
loro nuovi centri di ricerca anzichè
metterti a londra cambridge francoforte
li mettono a milano vicino all
nostra sede ma non solo perché questo la
ricerca che si fa il monte proprio
grazie ai meccanismi flessibili che
abbiamo messo in campo potrà essere da
un lato in molti casi svolta in
partnership con aziende private quindi
facendo aumentare ancora gli
investimenti in ricerca e soprattutto
darà luogo a ricadute di tipo
tecnologico e di tipo quindi economico
perché ci saranno nuove molecole nuove
terapie nuovi prodotti per migliorare la
salute delle persone che andranno
sviluppati commercializzati
industrializzati perché non
dimentichiamoci che senza
l'industrializzazione e scoperte
rimangono nei laboratori
questo perche possano essere diffuse
così che tutti li possono vedere c'è un
altro elemento fondamentale che è
l'abitudine e impatto della scienza che
ha sul resto della società il metodo
scientifico la discussione sulla scienza
e l'importanza della consapevolezza che
la scienza è un bene comune di una cosa
che finisce per migliorare la qualità di
tutta la società non solo di chi si
occupa di scienza la salute come sta
dicendo l'ambiente insieme al digitale
saranno grandi destinatari degli
investimenti pubblici e privati nei
prossimi anni dopo quello che è successo
nel 2020 il credo che noi siamo
diventati tutti consapevoli
quando saranno quali saranno il risponde
gelido human tecar popper garantisce un
flusso adeguato di risorse
diciamo un flusso di risorse adeguato
alle sue ambizioni
innanzitutto noi abbiamo una dotazione
di fondi pubblici importante stabile nel
tempo che rappresenta lo zoccolo di
partenza su cui costruire ma la cosa
fondamentale è che noi per noi queste
risorse non sono il tutto ma sono la
base quindi noi innanzitutto già stiamo
offrendo dei fondi da internazionali
perché gli scienziati che noi stiamo
assumendo siccome sono scienziati di
grande qualità hanno già delle dotazioni
di finanziamenti europei o di altre ed
enti filantropici o di altri enti che
danno finanziamenti alla ricerca di tipo
b momento
quindi quando vengono man tecnopolo
vengono come dire con la loro scorta di
risorse già disponibili quindi questo
rappresenta già un aumento di risorse
dopo di che stiamo costruendo un grande
office cosiddetto c'è un ufficio che si
occupa solo di aiutare gli scienziati a
fare domande di finanziamento questo è
fondamentale perché soprattutto nel
campo biomedico nelle scienze della vita
le fonti potenziali finanziamento sono
moltissimi sono quelle europee
ma come diceva ci sono quelle private di
vario genere fondazioni private che
nascono e crescono solo per dare
finanziamenti alla ricerca biomedica ci
sono di tanti tipi ma è importante anche
se organizzati per poterle per poter
fare le domande per poter fare in modo
che lo scienziato pensi alla ricerca non
si preoccupi troppo diciamo delle parti
burocratiche che però naturalmente sono
importanti ecco questi tipi di
finanziamenti e inoltre grazie alla
dimensione delle nostre infrastrutture
noi potremmo anche fare finalmente da
non da soli ma naturalmente partecipando
anche con altre istituzioni italiane
potremmo ambire a raccogliere di
finanziamenti per ricerche di grande
scala che sono finanziamenti
naturalmente significativi una cosa è
fare una piccola ricerca una cosa è
sequenziale
decine i miliardi cine decine di
migliaia di genova per esempio per
progetti genomici di grande scala in cui
in questo secondo caso le risorse
necessarie sono moltissime
servono tante istituzioni che si
coalizzano insieme per trovare questi
soldi e poi bisogna naturalmente fare
dei buoni progetti di ricerca è vero che
noi abbiamo un finanziamento importante
ma quel finanziamento pubblico va
considerato una base di partenza non va
considerata una cosa su cui stare seduti
accontentarsi
ho detto prima la scienza è un bene
comune come l'interprete human techno
paul questa affermazione e poi
cosa ne pensa della qualità della
comunicazione che la scienza utilizza
perché dopo un anno di pandemia
riteniamo che ci sia molto da fare in
questo senso quali sono due domande un
po diverse scienze al bene comune è
stato chiarito molto durante questa
mattina in due modi il primo è più è
forte l'eco sistema scientifico di un
paese fatto di laboratori di scienziati
più e preparato il paese per affrontare
qualsiasi incertezza e la pandemia da
uno strato con grande forza
la comunicazione invece è un tema nuovo
e diverso perché un tema nuovo perché
noi siamo abituati
siamo cresciuti in un mondo del
novecento il ma il mondo del novecento
quello che succedeva era che se tu hai
uno scienziato se tu eri qualsiasi
professione tu facevi potevi essere
sentirsi con la coscienza in pace
facendo il suo dovere il tuo ufficio
della mattina alla sera
come tutti oggi non è più così perché
perché in quell epoca in cui siamo
cresciuti esistevano i cosiddetti corpi
intermedi i sindacati i partiti le
parrocchie le associazioni c'è luoghi in
cui le persone di diverse estrazioni si
incontravano e costruivano una grande
fiducia sociale attorno le cose diverse
che facevano oggi non è più così viviamo
in una società molto atomizzate molto
frammentata per cui per quanto riguarda
per cui diventa dovere parte della
professione io credo dello scienziato e
parte della missione di un istituto come
il nostro quello di comunicare
l'orizzonte mente quello che fa col
resto della società io faccio uno sforzo
come oggi ad esempio per parlare e
chiedo costantemente alte tutti gli
scienziati di oman tecnopolo di fare lo
stesso non in quanto come dire come una
cosa aggiuntiva alla loro
professionalità ma come parte integrante
della loro professionalità perché in
questo momento chiunque faccia una
professione intellettuale e specialmente
gli scienziati deve porsi come
preoccupazione costante del proprio
lavoro
il fatto che l'utilità sociale di quello
che loro fanno sia chiara e si è diffusa
per fare questa cosa l'unico modo è
sedersi a un tavolo in maniera
orizzontale non sapere su una cattedra
quando sono l'università sta su una
cattedra
insegna agli studenti la politica
economica internazionale ma quando io
non sto in quell'aula non sono un
professore di economia sono una persona
che si occupa di economia che dirigono
centro di ricerca e quindi ne parlò
seduto in maniera sullo stesso piano
delle altre persone comunque sto
conquistò conversando che avranno delle
cose altrettanto interessanti da dirmi
qualunque sia il loro lavoro io credo
che vada però vissuta con una cosa
regolare da fare e costante su cui
impegnarsi parte il proprio lavoro
se fosse un giovane di 18 anni cosa che
non sono più io farei carte false per
venire a lavorare a human tecnopolo
comunque diciamo nel comprensorio che
aveva preso il nome di mani del milan
ovation decide e dove una techno pop
risiede
che cosa si sente di dire ai ragazzi
[Musica]
anche alle ragazze che si si come
inizieranno la loro professione nel 2025
2025 2030 e risiedono in una in un
territorio che a due passi da questo
fantastico investimento ma io ho dire
qualcosa anche a ragazzi e ragazze che
magari stanno in sicilia in puglia non
posso lontanissimo dal punto vista del
nostro paese rispetto a monte col o che
stanno magari un altro paese europeo
rispetto a noi e che noi siamo un luogo
aperto e che loro sono benvenuti di
cercare di venire a lavorare da noi se
sono interessati ai nostri tempi sono
interessati nella ricerca scientifica se
hanno il desiderio di dedicarsi che poi
non è solo un desiderio è anche una
missione a alla ricerca e l'avanzamento
della della conoscenza umana di avere
molta fiducia nel fatto che ci sono
tante persone in questo momento non
soltanto in italia e non soltanto da noi
che stanno lavorando per dare loro delle
opportunità in più è che noi siamo
sicuri che sapranno cogliere queste
opportunità di naturalmente dipenderà
dal loro impegno della loro dedizione
grazie professor simoni
o fratture del buon lavoro grazie mille
anche lei buon lavoro arrivederci a due
pc
[Musica]